en el mismo lugar de los hechos arrancó
este martes la investigación
parlamentaria sobre el ataque al
capitolio del 6 de enero cuando cientos
de seguidores del entonces presidente de
donald trump quisieron impedir la
confirmación de la victoria electoral de
joe biden en la primera sesión de la
comisión bipartidista creada por la
cámara de representantes- cuatro
policías revivieron el que pensaron iba
a ser su último momento aquí filmar
notaba que me faltaba el oxígeno me
recuerdo diciéndome a mí mismo así es
cómo voy a morir defendiendo esta
entrada
los agentes coincidieron en la necesidad
de llegar a la cima de la cadena de
responsabilidades sobre el ataque en
alusiones claras al expresidente trump
el tiempo el lugar y las circunstancias
de este ataque la retórica y lo
acontecido para mí señala en dirección a
nuestro presidente y a otros miembros no
sólo del congreso también del senado
acusaciones políticas que el propio
congresista adam kinzinger uno de los
dos únicos republicanos que integran la
comisión compartió como muchos
estadounidenses estoy frustrado porque
seis meses después de que una
insurrección mortal irrumpió en el
capitolio durante varias horas todavía
no sepamos lo que pasó porque porque
muchas personas de mi partido han
tratado de esto como si fuera solo otra
discusión partidista los nueve miembros
de la comisión fueron elegidos por la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes la demócrata nancy pelosi
que impidió que los fieles seguidores de
trump participaran en ella el ala
radical de los republicanos considera la
investigación una farsa pero la
indagación parlamentaria se desarrolla
en paralelo a la policial 500 personas
han sido interpeladas por su
participación en el asalto
la mayoría se delataron a sí mismas al
alardear de sus acciones en redes
sociales